casting a key role can be critical to a
film success particularly when it comes
to characters that have been deeply
explored before unfortunately in the
cases of these films and TV features the
casting decisions were downright awful
the first look at Joseph Fiennes in the
role of Michael Jackson for an episode
of urban myths led to immediate backlash
he was another groan worthy installment
of The Hollywood whitewashing tradition
that seemed like blatant disrespect
towards the former King of Pop following
the backlash the network decided to pull
the episode writing this decision was
taken in light of the concerns expressed
by Michael Jackson's immediate family we
set out to take a light-hearted look at
reportedly true events and never
intended to cause any offence Joseph
Fiennes fully supports our decision
Keanu Reeves has quite a few
performances to his name that just make
you say the one that takes the cake
though is his supporting role as
Jonathan Harker in Bram Stoker's Dracula
despite the fact that the film won three
Oscars for its costuming sound effects
and makeup crews Reeves portrayal was
marred by a terrible British accent and
over-the-top reactions doctor you must
understand everything even my mind
director Francis Ford Coppola kindly
remarked that Reeves tried hard when it
came to speaking with an English
affectation but that so much effort was
ultimately the issue with his portrayal
saying he wanted to do it perfectly and
then trying to do it perfectly it came
off as stilted M night Shyamalan was on
a real cold streak by the time he
decided to helm a live-action adaptation
of the animated series avatar at the
Last Airbender unfortunately the movie
flopped both critically and at the box
office part of the blame for the
box-office bomb has to go to Shyamalan
casting white actors such as Jackson
Rathbone and Nicola Peltz in Asian roles
as a result of his role casting
decisions the film was met with wide
race bending protests that called into
question why the filmmaker didn't opt
for a more culturally representative set
of actors arguably the biggest problem
in spider-man 3 is the character of
Eddie Brock aka venom when the movie was
first announced fans were psyched
see who Sony would cast for the role as
the popular spider-man villain but
somehow Topher Grace and nabbed the role
I want to kill the spider you want to
kill the spider together he doesn't
stand a chance
interested in the comics Eddie Brock is
a physically imposing guy Topher Grace
on the other hand isn't exactly mr.
universe even the actor himself was
baffled when he was offered the gig
speaking at an episode of the inside of
you podcast grace said he was a huge fan
of the character and sees Tom Hardy's
betrayal as a more accurate version I
was surprised and a little bit like ha
when they wanted me to play it so when I
look at it now I go I mean the movie
that's coming out I go like that's the
guy in prometheus guy Pierce plays Peter
Weyland the ancient and affluent CEO of
the villainous Weyland corporation
Weyland is hoping to find something out
in space that will help him beat death
one look at his face and we can see why
the horrible prosthetics are incredibly
distracting and despite his acting chops
Pierce is never convincing as an old man
Pierce later explained that there was in
fact supposed to be a dream sequence
showing Weyland as a younger man which
was the sole reason he was cast instead
of an elderly actor director Ridley
Scott decided to scrap the scene and
keep Pierce and his unsightly
prosthetics anyway when it comes to
directing M night Shyamalan either
strikes out hard or knocks the ball out
of the park but when it comes to sham
Ilan's acting the only time sis
performances work or when he relegates
himself to a Hitchcock style cameo when
he actually tries to act you'd wish he'd
spent all of his time behind the camera
that's especially true in lady in the
water sham Ellen's character Vic ran is
crucial to the plot and unfortunately
he's stiff and dry a cardboard cutout
come to life the whole thing is
especially embarrassing because
Shyamalan who writes his own screenplays
plays an author who is writing a book so
important that is going to change the
course of human events what an ego
working with director bong joon-ho Jake
Gyllenhaal starred as dr. Johnny Wilcox
in the 2017 film oak jaw the story
follows a young Korean girl named Amiga
as she tries to rescue her best friend a
genetically modified super pig named
okhta from an all-powerful american
corporation that wants to turn her into
pork chops an inner quest to rescue
okhta nietzsche runs across dr. Johnny a
shrill TV host who spends his time
screaming sobbing and acting like a
sadist while dr. Johnny could have been
an interesting character and fun bad guy
Gyllenhaal's instincts here are just all
wrong
he hits the highest decibel possible
with every single line he squeals and
whines and there's never a moment where
we see dr. Johnny is anything other than
a clown bong joon-ho movies generally
excel at giving graceful and powerful
moments to oddball characters but
Gyllenhaal is so loud and overwhelming
that not even his awesome mustache can
make for those over-the-top antics in
the year 2017
you'd think Hollywood would finally
realize that casting culturally
appropriate actors is a good idea but
evidently the folks at Lionsgate missed
the memo when casting their Hellboy
reboots everybody was happy when David
Harper signed up to play the big red
half-demon but the internet lost its
collective mind when Ed screen was
tapped to star as major Ben daimyo if
you're not familiar with Hellboy lore
bin daimyo is a member of the BPRD and a
US Marine who came back to life after a
rescue mission gone wrong he's also
japanese-american head scrying of
Deadpool Fame on the other hand is very
much a white dude so naturally some
people were pretty upset about the news
and the online furor prompted scrying to
step down from the part he described his
decision to leave the project as the
right thing to do and the only thing to
do and Lionsgate rectified their mistake
by recasting daimyo with Daniel Dae Kim
granted Kim is Korean American and not
Japanese but that's still better than
casting a white guy best known for
playing villains with British accents
gah my welcome speech needs to be full
of youthfulness inside
this may hurt a little and this may
cause you some discomfort
directed by David Ayer Suicide Squad is
maybe the most controversial DC EU movie
to date maybe that's because it
underwent some major reshoots or maybe
it's because they were just far too many
characters in one film in fact there
were so many bad guys running around
that one particular villain got very
little time in the spotlight the Joker
Jared Leto isn't a horrible Joker but he
didn't really add anything to the role
either the Clown Prince of Crime is the
most iconic villain in comic book
history and you really need a special
actor to bring him to life but Leto
relies too much on his flashy grille and
psycho eccentricities he snarls and
grimaces and does a kooky laugh but you
never feel the monster brimming under
all that makeup I am NOT someone who is
I'm an idea
State of Mind on August 21st 2015
three American friends stopped a heavily
armed psycho on a train heading from
Amsterdam to Paris the friends were
Spencer stone Alek skarlatos and Anthony
Sadler and together they took the
alleged terrorists down and saved
everyone on the train their story of
bravery made quite an impression on
director Clint Eastwood who turned the
story into a motion picture only instead
of hiring professional actors to play
the three leads he decided to cast the
actual guys who were aboard the train
that fateful day obviously these three
men were incredibly courageous but being
a real-life hero doesn't mean you can
play one when the 15:17 de paris pulled
into movie theaters critics paid their
respects to the trio's heroism but had
to admit that none of these dudes were
going to be the next Daniel day-lewis it
was a bold move by Eastwood to give
these guys a chance at movie stardom but
by the end of the film it's very
apparent why big-time actors make the
big bucks over 30 years after getting
turned into a big game trophy in the
original Shane Black returned to the
world of predator in 2018 only this time
he was behind the camera and directing a
cast that included Olivia Munn Jacob
Tremblay sterling Kate brown and
keegan-michael key in addition to those
big names black hired one of his good
friends for a small role stephen wilder
Striegel had known black for years in
fact he appeared in some of the
directors earlier films like Iron Man 3
and the nice guys Striegel was to play
an annoying jogger who hits on Olivia
Munn's character in a brief scene and
the predator and then this happened a
scene was taken out of the new predator
film after a last-minute revelation that
one of the actors involved is a
convicted sex offender when Munn
discovered her co-stars background
she told 20th Century Fox and the studio
cut Striegel scene out of the movie
Irish actor Colin Farrell has had a fair
number of acclaim worthy performances
but his eponymous turn and Alexander was
not one of them not only has his casting
been pan because he's not you know Greek
but he wasn't convincing as the amoral
emporia
Farrell for his part has been able to
laugh off the criticism particularly
when it comes to his terrible bleached
blond locks he gave an interview on the
Graham Norton Show in 2013 where he
suggested some retroactive changes you
should have been / - sure maybe you
shouldn't have had an Irish accent 7000
reviews I ready even George Clooney
knows that his casting his Bruce Wayne
was all wrong almost as wrong as the
entirety of 1997 s Batman and Robin as
Clooney recalled in a hilarious
interview with the Graham Norton Show
he doesn't mind apologizing for the role
I always apologize you know I thought at
the time this was going to be a very
good career move it wasn't
[Music]